our rated films are supposed to push
your buttons with freedom to deliver
language blood nudity and drug use you
can provide lots of provocative material
in some instances though R-rated movies
use the creative freedom of their rating
for Less Savory purposes these are the
films that go too far
every generation gets their own take on
the classic story The Most Dangerous
Game and this generation's Incarnation
came with the hunt this Craig zobel film
concerns a group of people who wake up
and find out they're being hunted for
sports like any version of this tale
does the twist this time though as the
story got filtered through the modern
day political Zeitgeist with the hunters
being left leaning Elites while the
victims were coded as conservatives on
paper it's easy to see how the project
received a green light as something that
in the vein of Team America will police
could generate political discourse while
drumming up ticket sales from moviegoers
who wanted to be part of the
conversation and the dark humor however
the marketing for the hunt inspired a
wave of unforeseen controversy largely
from right-leaning news organizations it
even garnered an implied response from
former presidents Donald Trump who
accused Hollywood of Millie trying to
stir up violence the cause of all that
brouhaha was that many saw the hunters
endorsing violence against conservatives
though this seemed to ignore how their
conservative of characters were the
heroes of the movie still the Uproar
over the hunt had a sizable impact and
inspired the film to get delayed a whole
six months when it came time for this
generation's most dangerous game perhaps
the filmmakers tried to push a few too
many buttons
our rated comedies can sometimes draw
flag for getting too racy with certain
jokes but the interview inspired a whole
other level of vitriol the film about
super goofballs getting pressed into
assassinating Kim Jong-un Drew negative
responses from North Korea especially a
scene depicting the leader's gruesome
death in fact the film was so
controversial that it inspired a hack
apparently stemming from North Korea
that leaked countless pieces of
sensitive information all stemming from
distributor Sony Pictures things got
even crazier when the hackers eventually
graduated to threatening extreme
violence against movie theaters that
screamed the interview the consequences
of the film's provocative humor were
Swift by mid-December the movie's
theatricor release was largely canned
but that wasn't the end of the interview
on the contrary the movie continued to
inspire widespread discussion on how to
respond when violent threats are made
against artists in the Years census
released the interview actor and
co-director Seth Rogen has been upfront
on what a grueling experience at all was
Rogan said to Cinema Blend truthfully
after the interview co-director Evan
Goldberg and I were a little traumatized
I think like many of Rogan's comedies
the interview was something that could
provoke laughs but was also meant to
push buttons but nobody could have
expected the outsized and unprecedented
response is mature you're received
the Anthology comedy movie 43 provides
more stars than there are in the heavens
across its various individual segments
whereas wall-to-wall crudeness and other
comedies can help unearth some kind of
deeper truth about Humanity movie 43 is
now widely regarded as one of the worst
comedies to ever hit theater screens the
participation of movie stars ranging
from Hugh Jackman to Richard Gere to
Emma Stone couldn't help Elevate the
film The only conversation drummed up by
this box office stud was a handful of
horrific moments that showed the film's
desperation to ring jugs from moviegoers
movie 43 employed yellowface incest and
a closing sequence largely focused on
physical abuse being hold of a character
played by Elizabeth Banks movie 43
embraced the idea of overloading the
viewer on shocking material though the
movie pushed the boundaries of what the
R rating would allow movie 43 was Hollow
vulgarity to its very core
released in 2011 The Hangover Part 2
drew some heavy criticism for going way
too far at its attempts to be funny for
example many people were outraged when
the character of Stu learned that he
slept with a transgender woman
of course not we just have some fun in
the Chardonnay room the depiction of
this Revelation as being disgusting was
correctly labeled by many as an example
of bro comedies using blatant
transphobia as a substitute for actual
comedy garnering even more media
attention at the time was a photo in the
end credits the image parodies an actual
photo taken in the Vietnam War of a
South Vietnamese General executing a
prisoner the moment was dubbed by
critics like Roger Ebert as a
desecration of one of the most famous
photos to come out of the Vietnam War
here fans were disappointed that a movie
that was all about shock value crossed
over from providing adult skewing gags
into outright disrespect
it's like a Mary make upono is actually
a sweet movie when you get right down to
it one about lifelong best friends who
may actually have romantic feelings for
one another However the fact that it had
the word porno in its title meant the
film already rubbed some moviegoers the
wrong way this was especially true in
the movie's marketing which kicked off
with a poster that proved so suggestive
that it ended up getting banned from
being shown in movie theaters sometimes
a movie that stirs up this much
controversy can ride all the publicity
to sizable box office success
unfortunately none of these marketing
troubles inspired much interest from
moviegoers released at the very end of
October 2008 Zack and Miri Make a Porno
ended up sinking Without a Trace at the
box office the Kevin Smith comedy
despite featuring raunchy scenes like
Justin long as an adult film star
listening off the titles of movies he's
appeared in is ultimately a film that
wants to Target your heartstrings too
bad it's marketing garnered a reputation
for being all the wrong kinds of
boundary pushing
released in 2007 The Hills Have Eyes 2
is the kind of schlucky horror B movie
that audiences tend to watch because of
its tasteless material graphic violence
especially is a forte of their sub-genre
however this particular horror sequel
use its sensibilities not to depict over
the top violence but to continue a long
tradition of using sexual assault in a
throwaway manner The Hills Have Eyes too
sent as much of its plot on the prospect
of deformed mutants capturing human
women for the purposes of forced
breeding the movie's emphasis on this
element is made apparent in an opening
scene Wanda depicting an unnamed woman
trapped in the mutants basement solely
so she can breed children before she can
establish even the barest personality
she slaughtered after birthing a
stillborn baby critics like Scott Tobias
took the hills of eyes too to Tusk for
resorting to such a shallow depiction of
sexual assault as well as for not giving
any of the women in the film basic
character development while some
Grindhouse movies like Abel ferrara's
miss 45 have gone and praise for using
grimy exploitation Cinema to
thoughtfully explore the perspective of
a sexual assault Survivor that titleless
treatment of sexual assault in the Hills
advice too is just plain appalling
the 2007 over Bowl movie postal opens
with a sequence depicting flight 11 just
moments before it hits the North Tower
beginning the 9 11 terrorist attacks in
this version of the event the two
hijackers piloting the plane decided to
have bought the mission only for the
passengers to break into the cockpit and
inadvertently cause the plane to crash
into the tower a sequence like this was
always meant to establish the tasteless
and if the general critical reception is
any indicator humorless ascetic of the
movie ahead but the film's opening gag
was perceived by many as way too
provocative to the point that one of its
actors believed it caused the film its
commercial potential in the book my era
flops by Nathan Rabin performer Dave
Foley remarked I think that crashing a
plane into the Twin Towers at the start
of the film hurting posts still like his
video game Source material wanted to
shock and defend but it seems that it
went above and beyond the Call of Duty
in its opening sequence which took
things from vulgar comedy to just plain
vulgar
this Cuba Gooding Junior and a ratio
sand story concerns two men who enlist
in a singles cruise only to discover
exclusively for gay men they then pose
as gay while trying to get closer to
women who work on the boat the comedy is
full of jokes about straight men being
terrified of the very presence of gay
people and how gross the thought of two
dudes kissing is critics Savage the film
for its rampant homophobia though many
writers also slam the movie for being
too tedious Rita kembly of the
Washington Post for example remarks that
the tired and familiar attempts at
comedy were just as insulting as a
rampant gay Panic material adding that
it's time many of the movie's more
offensive gags went back into the closet
few films of the 1990s are as
controversial As Natural Born Killers
the tale of murderous lovers Mickey and
Mallory played by Woody Harrelson and
Juliet Lewis intended by writer and
director Oliver Stone as a condemnation
of the heavy presence of violence in the
media the general response to the movie
is still divided today over whether or
not the film achieved its intended goals
criticton at Muslim for instance
observes that the movie seems to be more
in love with graphic violence and
critical of it marslin observed while
Natural Born Killers affects occasional
disgusts at the Lord world of Mickey and
Mallory it more often seems enamored of
their exhilarating Freedom critics who
interpreted the film as being more of a
love letter to this kind of behavior saw
Natural Born Killers there's a lot of
ultraviolent noise without much of a
purpose similarly much has been written
about how the film's treatment of
indigenous cultures is almost a stomach
churning as its most gruesome instance
of violence with this 1994 film Stone
meant to make something that inspired a
reaction in people he succeeded but
fortunately it inspired a whole lot of
critiques as Stone and made something as
indulgent as the elements of society he
intended to condemn
whatever I'm Stan Wayne you and me were
not even saying species I used to be you
then I evolved
Revenge of the Nerds has often been seen
as a film championing The downtrodden a
comedic form of voyeurism wherein the
oppressed could live out their greatest
fantasies now for many Revenge of the
Nerds are seen as trivializing rape
culture this is most apparent in an
Infamous sequence where the character of
Lewis pretends to be the jokestan so he
can sleep with the quarterback's
girlfriend Betty it's meant to be a
cheer-worthy sequence in the movie
itself but it registers to many now as
an endorsements of sexual assault
director Jeff canoe himself has recently
expressed regrets over ever including
the scene in the film in 2019 canoe told
GQ I've heard criticism a lot this year
because of the metoo movement at the
time it was considered sort of a switch
it's not excusable if it were my
daughter I probably wouldn't like it the
R-rated events of Revenge of the Nerds
were intended to be seen as conventional
escapism but it's apparent to many now
that the movie is more Insidious than
humorous
in his voyage of the river to find
Marlon Brando's Colonel Kurtz Martin
Sheen's Captain Willard sees a wide
array of horrific and Unforgettable
sights that lay the horrors of the
Vietnam War bare unfortunately viewers
are also exposed to a terrible sight
late in the film for a climactic scene
involving a ritual performed by an
ifagal tribe a water buffalo is killed
on screen this was apparently a
real-life practice that was already
underway before cameras started rolling
with director Francis Ford Coppola
filming the ritual as it occurred while
intended to be a visual parallel to
Willard's plan to assassinate ker to the
machete the sight of an animal killed on
screen is drying enough to render that
thematic undercurrent irrelevant decades
after the film's release Coppola has
stood by the scene reaffirming that he
was merely documenting reality itself
Coppola said to USA Today I did not
direct it or anything that was the way
they do it to prove his point Coppola
made sure to emphasize that he refused
to have an extra water buffalo around to
kill in case extra takes were needed
despite Coppola's statements the scene
of animal cruelty stands out in
Apocalypse Now as horrifying for all the
wrong reasons check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]